one line in the hawkeye series
referenced a big event in spider-man no
way home and even if you've been keeping
up you still might have missed it here
are the other big easter eggs only real
fans noticed in spider-man no way home
spider-man no way home goes to some dark
places but there's a lot of joy and
humor in the movie's more creative
moments especially all the parts where
universes collide jamie foxx's revamped
version of electro is arguably the
funniest character in the whole film
even though they're from different
universes his max dylan strikes up an
amusing relationship with thomas hayden
church's sandman
during the movie they both realized
their superpowers were given to them via
some kind of horrible accident flint
marco fell into a particle accelerator
while dylan fell into a pool of
genetically engineered electric eels as
elektro says to sandman looking back on
their mutual mishaps you gotta be
careful where you fall
another one of the movie's fun
referential lines comes from star high
school reporter betty brandt newly aware
of peter parker's dual life she remarks
at one point go get him tiger or should
i say spider
tigers
it's been a long dramatic somewhat
confusing road
the line is fun for a couple of reasons
first of all it makes sense on its own
because peter's school mascot at the
midtown school happens to be the tigers
that itself would seem to be a bit of a
reference to a classic catchphrase of
mary jane watson
go get him tiger
of course kirsten dunst's delivery of
the line was itself paying homage to
mary jane watson in the comics who has
been fond of the pet name tiger since
her first appearance in the 1960s mary
jane herself may never quite appear in
the mcu spider-man movies betty paying
homage to mj classic's fave pet name
another intriguing one-liner reference
in no way home occurs when peter is
brought into an interrogation-like
situation following his exposure as
spider-man while trying to defend
himself peter parker says that nick fury
could vouch for his heroic actions but
he's promptly told that nick fury has
been off planet for the last year
what
in case you've not been keeping up
between the events of the last avengers
films and spider-man far from home it
was established that nick fury has been
off on a most mysterious adventure
somewhere in outer space when nick fury
returned from his disappearance during
the blimp he attended tony stark's
funeral and then apparently arranged to
have the skrulls talos and sauron
impersonate him and maria hill we don't
know the exact reason why yet but the
arrangement seems to be in place that he
or possibly he and maria both can take a
long work trip slash vacation and outer
space the scenario was teased explicitly
in a post-credits scene for spider-man
far from home showing nick fury looking
surprisingly comfortable during his
mission aboard a skrull spaceship
whatever he's doing out there his own
personal star trek seems likely to be
wrapping up soon with the timing to
coincide with the upcoming secret
invasion series on disney plus which
will reportedly shine a light on the
shape-shifting scrolls mysterious
activities on planet earth
one no way home easter egg isn't even in
the movie itself so you definitely
shouldn't feel bad if you missed this
one
hi
in the fifth episode of the disney plus
series hawkeye the new black widow
yelena balova talks about being in new
york city for the first time she makes a
reference to wanting to visit various
landmarks including the new and improved
statue of liberty i want to see
the empire state building
the new and improved statue of liberty
and
the rockefeller center in a hawkeye
series this comment doesn't quite make
sense but when you see no way home it
all starts to fit together in the movie
we see that the statue of liberty is
under construction to replace its torch
with captain america's shield and the
scene plays host to the movie's
climactic final battle since small
indications like christmas music and
decorations seem to pinpoint no way home
is taking place in december and the
hawkeye series explicitly takes place
near christmas it seems like hawkeye and
no way home are set fairly close to each
other in the series continuity
arguably the most entertaining scenes in
no way home have nothing to do with car
wrecking highway confrontations or
statue of liberty smackdowns the real
fun happens during a handful of quiet
moments when spidey and his two new
spider-man pals played by andrew
garfield and toby maguire compare notes
on their three somewhat similar but
often distinct universes both maguires
peter and holland's peter have an mj
garfield does not holland and maguire
have both bought aliens garfield has not
but perhaps the most enjoyable bit of
shop talk is the trio's discussion of
toby mcguire's organic web shooters
which you might recall became a hugely
controversial issue in those simpler
days back in 2002 when hollywood saw
superhero movies as more of a box office
gamble at the time director sam raimi
essentially said it made more sense that
someone bitten by a radioactive spider
taking on the qualities of a spider
would be able to shoot webs biologically
it seemed to make more sense he reasoned
than having peter coincidentally possess
the scientific and engineering acumen to
invent web shooters these days audiences
are used to peter parker's web shooters
being built by somebody as in the comics
that makes it all the more entertaining
to hear the questions the other two
spider-men have for meguiar's peter
parker does he ever get the web
equivalent of writer's block do any
other parts of his body shoot web fluid
those wings carving fiber is this stuff
coming out of you the three spiderman in
no way home essentially represent peter
parker at various stages in his life
holland is the naive earnest youngster
garfield the jaded heartbroken loner and
maguire still apparently in a
relationship with mary jane has learned
how to balance it all and find some
semblance of happiness
one of the most memorable powerful
moments from the spider-man franchise
came in 2014's the amazing spider-man 2
when an imperiled gwen stacy fell from a
high distance as peter grappled with a
villain desperately trying to save her
peter shot a web but it was too late
this tragic death of gwen stacy of
course mirrored one of the most famous
moments in comic book history another
memorable moment in the franchise came
in 2002's spider-man when willem dafoe's
norman osborne attempted to use the
blades of his green goblin glider to
impale maguire's peter parker from
behind leaping out of the way at the
last moment spidey lived to see another
day but osborne was killed in no way
home maguire is the spider-man who steps
in when hollin's peter parker gives into
his rage and is about to similarly kill
osborne with the goblin glider andrew
garfield's spider-man meanwhile has a
powerful moment coming to holland's aid
when mj falls from the statue of liberty
this time in a powerful moment rather
than watching another love of peter
parker's life die the andrew garfield
spider-man is able to successfully shoot
a web and save her
when peter's secret identity gets outed
he and his friends are detained early in
the film by damage control a men in
black like government agency that seems
adjacent to shield they appear to be
primarily interested in issues of
concealment in public relations while
this isn't the first time mcu fans have
seen damage control it's possibly the
most substantial mentions of damage
control go all the way back to the
original iron man film and they're
referenced on an episode of agents of
shield shield will take all the wounded
men into custody and damage control will
clean up
in spider-man homecoming the agency
fired adrian toombs aka the vulture from
engaging in his private scrap operation
instead they took over the cleanup of
sensitive materials in nyc and set
events in motion that would lead to much
of that film's plot in 2015 marvel
announced that the damage control
organization was going to be the subject
of a comedy on abc obviously the series
never made it to air and it seems quite
likely that many of those ideas have
begun seeping their way into mcu story
lines like what we see in no way home
but none of this is all that new for
fans of marvel comics who have been
encountering damage control since 1988
and saw the organization play a
substantial role in the civil war comics
multiple spider-men are swell but you
can be forgiven if the cameo that
excites you most in no way home comes at
the beginning of the film when peter
finds himself in legal hot water happy
and aunt may sit him down with none
other than matt murdock played once
again by marvel fan favorite charlie cox
that's it let the devil out
marvel studios president kevin feige
recently told cinemablend if you were to
see daredevil in upcoming things charlie
cox yes would be the actor playing
daredevil where we see that how we see
that when we see that remains to be seen
well it didn't take long this is
exciting because it's the first
substantial crossover we've seen between
the mcu and the netflix live-action tv
shows and since daredevil ended its run
on netflix many fans had started to
think it would never happen
seeing cox in no way home at the same
time that vincent d'onofrio made his
first appearance as kingpin in the fifth
episode of hawkeye makes for a thrilling
time in mcu phase four taken together
it's confirmation that feige and marvel
studios mean business when it comes to
bringing at least some of the netflix
characters back into the mcu
so the devil is back
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spiderman no way home are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you